scorpion capital a short seller released
a short report on ginkgo bioworks and
the stock is down around 20 so far today
remember we had jason kelly
from ginkgo bioworks uh on episode
1239 of this very podcast so that was
this year
they are a synthetic biology company uh
that claimed to have an interesting
business model they would develop
products on a service based basis in
other words instead of them making the
products they would work with other
companies and they would essentially be
the amazon web services of synthetic
biology as opposed to other companies
that were going to build the products
themselves we'll get into that in a
minute
and
um jason was well spoken on the program
uh i did get a couple of dms that hey
this company is a little shaky maybe
they used other choice language
so i always take the approach here of
let the founders speak on our podcast
and
let them explain their business model
and here we go here's ginkgo
ceo describing their business model in
this 38 second clip let's talk about it
on the other side and by the way the way
gingko's business works is we're like
sell programmers for hire
okay right so i'm sitting in front of
like a 200 000 square foot compiler and
debugger for genetic code here in boston
it's like robotic automation doing what
i did back in grad school and then we
use that machine to basically program a
cell to meet a customer spec and then we
give it to them and we make money like
kind of like apple would make money in
the app store right like we we get like
a royalty or equity in their company or
some region
yeah that's a fascinating business model
so what's an example of a company that
sends you on a mission like this all
right so i'll give you what i like so
there's a company called chronos up in
canada it's a canadian cannabis company
all right altria owns like half of this
company
okay so what you see there is
explains their business model and i was
like well that's fascinating it's kind
of like an incubator plus a service
business so this would be as if amazon
web services or google cloud
um or azure from microsoft said hey
let's have you
uh come in and
we will um
you pay us to do your synthetic biology
research but we get some upside it's a
pretty good business model right it's
like an incubator plus service revenue
kind of interesting um would be like a
development shop building your app and
investing in your company
so uh we researched chronos um
and um it seems like they don't share
similar investors in ginkgo and if you
look at ginkgo and we'll get to that in
a minute why that's important ginkgo
billed themselves
as kind of an app store or aws for
synthetic biology this would be a
platform that other people could build
on top of right so they did us back back
in may at a 15 billion dollar valuation
uh and we officially started tracking
the dna stock so if you do a search for
dollar sign dna on twitter or you search
for that uh this pack was led by former
head of mgm
harry sloan i mean that's a little bit
of a mini red flag i don't know what mgm
has to do with
dna and synthetic biology so
we had a similar collapse
for another synthetic biology company
that we also had on the podcast on
episode 1231 i had been hearing about
synthetic biology from my bestie david
friedberg on all in i said okay what are
the i said to my parents what are the
synthetic biology companies let's get
jaycal and the audience up to speed on
them let's have them on and let's let
them talk well that company zymogen
announced that they were way off their
revenue predictions they'd make no
revenue in 2022 and they removed their
ceo josh hoffman who was on the program
all right so let's get back to ginkgo
this morning
which is wednesday october 6 2021 short
seller
scorpion capital released a report on
gitgo's business model calling it a and
then i'm going to put this in quotes a
colossal scam now scorpion is an
activist short seller just like
hindenburg research whose reports we
discussed on nicola nicolo also on the
program also uh
you know or i should say not also that
they turned out to be
really really um
seems like one of the biggest frauds
we're going to see
in a long time in silicon valley
scorpion uh released their first short
sell and is it interesting scorpio and
hindenburg it seems like all these short
sellers have to name themselves some
really scary deadly name scorpion and
hindenburg wow uh very evocative
good good uh good persuasive names i
would say in in
good branding really strong brands like
you think about hindenburg you think
about scorpion you don't want to be
involved and you don't want to
touch either one of those so
in april they released a report on
quantum scape the ev battery startup
that lost 85 percent of its value since
peaking at 130 a share in december of
2020
activist investors if you don't know
take a large position then they disclose
their rationale to the public in a pr
move uh the biggest examples would be
bill ackman's uh pershing square and
paul singer's elliott management i think
bill ackman was the one who did uh
herbalife that kind of blew up in his
face he wasn't able to convince the
world that that was an mlm scam
um which was his position
so you can read the following at
scorpion capitals twitter feed which is
scorpion fund one word
and here's the sixth tweet thread they
released this morning number one we are
short dna ginkgo bioworks is a colossal
scam uh frankenstein mashup of the worst
frauds
of the last 20 years at 23 billion
market cap it is rare to see a related
party scheme
on ginkgo scale in the us markets it is
quite simply the us version of the china
hustle in quotes
number two in the tweet storm and this
is a really important one eco
business model which i talked about in
that clip is based on a dubious shell
game
most of its foundry revenue i called it
um the foundry a um
an accelerator
uh and have served 72 percent in 2020
and almost 100 of its deferred revenue
are derived from related party and in
question and quotes customers
investments into these entities by
ginkgo and its investors are round
tripped back
and that is the key word in the sentence
round trip back what is round tripping
well let me give you
a little uh history lesson aol america
online
um had controlled much of the internet
in the early days and you're like how
did aol controlling it well there were
30 million people paying for aol at the
time and that was how people figured out
how to pick a website
uh people didn't have just like a dsl
connection largely then they would dial
up into aol and then aol would present
them like here's the choices of what's
on the web that's why they bought
netscape
and what they did was they did what were
called portal deals these portal deals
would cost
fifty million dollars a hundred million
dollars a lot of money at the time um in
today's
money there would be five hundred
million dollar deals let's say maybe
even billion
so they would sell a company i think it
was like cd now or music something
the music category they would sell
somebody the auto category so there
would be somebody who was trying to make
the yahoo of autos or the yahoo of music
or cds or movies and they would say okay
we would like you to pay us 50 million
dollars they might invest in the company
at the same time
50 million dollars so they'd say okay
we'll invest 50 million dollars into
your startup so when you take it public
we get the upside because ipos were
going crazy in the dot com days this was
the accusation then the money would then
the sales department would say okay give
us 50 million dollars in advertising
and it was like they wouldn't have the
50 million dollars if you hadn't
invested the 50 million dollars and this
is the shell game right that they're
talking about here
is and round tripping means the money
takes a round trip i give you the money
you give it back
okay everybody let's take a moment to
talk about growth marketing and all the
tactics and hacks that are out there
with me today jake basgard he is the ceo
and founder of disruptive advertising
which you can visit at
disruptiveadvertising.com
twist so some questions for you jake
when is too early to start marketing
your cyber monday uh or your black
friday what's the right time to engage
people and how do you engage them yeah
you know that's gonna depend on the
audience but that the cheapest customer
is the person that's already bought from
you before
and it's time today to start warming up
the audience that bought from you last
year
with custom audiences on social or email
it's time to get on top of those right
now and getting them warm and ready to
engage
as far as new audiences are concerned
there's a lot of opportunity to explore
new platforms outside of the traditional
google facebook
channels uh like uh instagram instagram
tick tock some of these other ones
linkedin
youtube let's get some new audiences in
place and test those out and find what's
working so that we're ready to scale
when game time comes all right that's
great advice so if you want to sign up
for a free digital marketing audit with
jake and his company disruptive
advertising just visit
disruptiveadvertising.com twist and if
you go into business with disruptive you
will receive a 250 gift card and a free
friday to sunday ski trip in utah uh
we'll see you on the slopes gonna be a
great season